foreign
[Music]
Twitter
um
yeah
foreign
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
foreign
started
[Music]
president secretary
course
foreign
Rosa
de more
because
foreign
[Music]
patreon
um
today
[Music]
foreign
uh
qualities
okay
was not at the shore is
um
foreign
[Music]
oil
repeat it
is
occupations
[Music]
president
is
consultancy
in the key instruments
foreign
[Music]
uh with Nelson is Africans
sentences
foreign
[Music]
sweetie
sure
is
[Music]
on
tomorrow
Alaska
thank you very very much
let me let me start by saying
how moving it was to join you this
morning in paying
tribute to uh
Ukraine's fallen soldiers who gave their
lives for the freedom of this country
we talk about numbers and statistics a
lot
but
standing there with dimitro
in front of the
Graves of the Fallen and seeing the
photographs
of each one
brings home powerfully the
real story
the human story
of
lives lost
cut short
because of this horrific Russian
aggression
and it's also a powerful reminder of the
extraordinary resilience
courage and determination of Ukrainian
people
and Ukraine's Armed Forces this is now
my sixth trip as Secretary of State to
Ukraine and the fourth since the Russian
full-scale invasion began February 24th
of 2022 and I keep seeing the same thing
that determination that resilience
um that commitment on the part of all
ukrainians
to build a future where they can live
safely and live freely and in a thriving
democracy fully integrated with Europe
Ukraine is the home of
incredibly proud people who are driven
by a fierce belief in themselves
in their freedom in their right to
choose their own path
a nation United by Common sacrifice
but fortified by the righteousness of
their fight
and that spirit is everywhere
I saw it again today in the men and
women who are reopening or visiting
businesses in Kiev in the children
returning to class for the new school
year
and the families and communities
defiantly continuing to live their lives
even as Putin seeks to end them
the United States is committed to
empowering Ukraine to write its own
future
in The Crucible of President Putin's
brutal and ongoing War
the United States and Ukraine have
forged a partnership that is stronger
than ever
and growing every day
we will continue to stand by Ukraine's
side and today we're announcing new
assistance totaling more than one
billion dollars in this common effort
that includes
665.5 million dollars in new military
and civilian security assistance in
total we committed over 43 billion
dollars in security assistance since the
beginning of the Russian aggression
now since I was last year almost exactly
one year ago Ukrainian forces have taken
back more than 50 percent of the
territory seized by Russian forces since
February of 2022. in the ongoing
counteroffensive
progress has accelerated in the past few
weeks this new assistance will help
sustain it and build further momentum
the assistance includes an additional
175 million dollars in drawdown
Authority that will provide significant
support for Ukraine's air defenses a
critical need as you've heard dimitro
say among other areas another 100
million in foreign military financing to
support Ukraine's longer term military
needs 300 million dollars to support law
enforcement efforts to restore and
maintain Law and Order in liberated
areas
we're sending our first delivery of mine
resistant and Bush protected vehicles to
Ukraine's border guards and police so
some of whom I'll have an opportunity to
visit with tomorrow
and we're providing critical assistance
for demining to help clear Russian
landmines unexploded ordinance and other
daily remnants of War killing and maybe
civilians
Ukraine is now the world's most heavily
mined country
30 percent of its territory is
potentially covered with mines
Russia's weapons of war have killed
hundreds of civilians and threatened to
put Millions at risk for years even
decades to come
the new security funding that we're
announcing today uh will also be
bolstered by the arrival of U.S Abrams
Tanks this fall and by training for
Ukrainian pilots on f-16s in the United
States complementing training that is
already underway in Europe
even as we maximize our support for
Ukraine to counter the current Russian
aggression
we're committed to helping Ukraine build
a force for the future that can deter
and defend against future regression
today with President zielinski I
discussed longer term sustainable
security Arrangements which will provide
ongoing security assistance and modern
military equipment across land air sea
and cyberspace
as well as training and intelligence
sharing the state department is leading
these discussions which will continue in
the months ahead
28 other countries are making similar
commitments through the G7 Declaration
of support for Ukraine
in no small part because they recognize
as the foreign minister said that
Ukraine security is integral to the
security of the entire euro-atlantic
community and indeed it's integral to
security around the world because of the
principles that are being challenged
here as well as Ukrainian lives and
livelihoods together
these 29 countries that are committed to
supporting Ukraine over the long term
coordinate and share the burden of that
long-term support
in the more immediate term we are
working with Congress across parties to
provide additional short-term funds in
the supplemental funding bill this month
at the same time we will continue to
support Ukraine as it works to build
International consensus for a just and
durable peace that upholds the U.N
Charter and its fundamental principles
of sovereignty territorial Integrity
Independence
Beyond Ukraine's security needs for the
first time we are transferring to
Ukraine asset seized from sanctioned
Russian oligarchs which will now be used
to support Ukrainian military veterans
those who have enabled Putin's War
regression should pay for it
we're continuing life-saving
humanitarian assistance emergency
shelter for those whose homes Russian
has destroyed
medical support and health care for
survivors of Relentless Russian missile
attacks and shelling
including as we saw again last night and
today
food clean drinking water generators for
communities
today we're committing an additional 206
million dollars toward that effort much
of which is dedicated to helping the
more than 6 million ukrainians who are
displaced by Russia's War
as Russia continues to weaponize food
we're helping people within Ukraine and
around the world who are suffering from
extreme hunger as well as malnutrition
not content with pulling out of the
Black Sea Grant initiative which is sent
32 million metric tons of Ukrainian
grain to the world the equivalent of
more than 18 billion loaves of bread
most of it to developing countries
Putin is now bombing Ukrainian granaries
and warehouses mining Port entrances
driving up food prices around the world
devastating Ukrainian farmers
now Russia claims it would be willing to
return to the Black Sea Grant initiative
if its conditions are met
the United Nations has put forward a
proposal that meets those conditions but
Putin continues to hold out
meanwhile
Russia is using the hunger and Market
Distortion that it's created to profit
from record-breaking exports of its own
brain
as we build International pressure on
Russia to return to the Black Sea Grant
initiative
we're working with Ukraine to find and
use alternative routes for its grain
shipments to other countries
for Ukraine not only to survive but to
thrive
we're also supporting its efforts to
rebuild from Russia's aggression
at the Ukraine recovery Conference held
in London a few months ago I pledge the
United States would invest more than 520
million dollars in making Ukraine's
energy infrastructure more than half of
which has been destroyed by Russia
cleaner more resilient and more
integrated with Europe
we're making new Investments to enhance
the transparency of Ukraine's
institutions and to bolster the rule of
law so that Ukraine's democracy is even
more responsive to the needs of its
people and can attract the private
Capital needed to rebuild
we're engaged in assisting the
government of Ukraine on any corruption
efforts and on efforts to ensure
accountability and full transparency of
all the assistance we're providing as
well as the security of U.S provided
defense articles and Technologies
president zielinski and I discussed
these issues today and the importance to
Ukraine's Democratic future
of continued reforms and the fight
against corruption
a few months ago in Helsinki
I spoke to how President Putin's war in
Ukraine has been and will continue to be
a strategic failure for Russia
there's no better demonstration of that
than seeing the Ukrainian people whose
national identity Putin sought to erase
stronger and more unified than ever
before
as I said then
no one has done more to intensify
ukrainian's determination to write their
own future on their own terms and
President Putin
now we have no illusions
the path forward will be easy but
this is a fight that we must and we will
win
for any country threatened by bullies
who would be aggressors
for all who seek a future of security
and peace
and my message today on behalf of
President Biden in the United States the
Ukrainian people is
just as we have stood with you
to ensure your nation's survival over
these past 20 months so we will stand
with you as you determine your future
and rebuild a free
resilience a thriving Ukraine
questions the first one goes to Wall
Street Journal William
thank you so much both of you
secretary blinken you said uh you have
no illusions that the fight will be easy
uh
what did you hear what one or two things
did you hear on this trip from president
zielinski or others that you can take
back to President Biden and the American
people and say this is a fight that
Ukraine can win or this is a fight that
it makes sense for the U.S to support
and also for foreign minister kaleba I
wanted to ask a similar question are you
at all worried about waning political
support for the war in Ukraine in the
United States
thank you
will thank you um
first as I said it's important to put
where we are where Ukraine is in
perspective as I mentioned a moment ago
I was last here almost exactly a year
ago and in that time in the year since I
was last here
Ukraine has taken back more than 50
percent of the territory that Russia has
seized from it since February of 2022.
in the current counter-offensive we are
seeing real progress over the last few
weeks as it happens president zielinski
just returned from the front line so I
was able to hear directly from him his
assessment of the counter-offensive uh
and I think it very much matches our own
which is as I said uh real progress in
in recent weeks
um
we are doing everything we can to
maximize our support to Ukraine as it
pursues the counter-offensive
and ultimately as I said before
one thing about above all other things
will make the difference I'm convinced
beyond the
extraordinary work that ukrainians are
doing Beyond even the equipment the
support of the training that we and
dozens of other nations are providing
the fundamental difference maker is that
ukrainians are fighting for their own
country for their own future for their
own Freedom Russians are not
and that gives me tremendous confidence
that Ukraine will prevail
as I mentioned I I believe that
secretary and this Administration and
both parties in the Congress
understand that what is being decided
here in Ukraine is not just about
Ukraine it's about the way the world
will look like because if Russia
manages to succeed even partially
it will be a clear motivational signal a
clear encouragement to all other malign
forces across the globe
to solve problems through the use of
force
the second argument is also I mean I I
think very very simple
I mean I don't want to sound rude but
the question is
if the West cannot win in this war then
what is the war that the West can win
and when I say the West I include
Ukraine to this to this list as well
but I think the most important part of
your answer was comes from the secretary
himself from his concluding lines that
Ukraine as you said should win and will
must win and will win
and this is exactly the philosophy that
is being
then implemented into specific decisions
that gives me reasons to believe
that we are continuing our work towards
Victory and it's deeply appreciated
um
[Music]
thank you very much uh first let me say
that um
for me
the the well-being the security the
safety of Americans everywhere
and particularly overseas is my number
one responsibility and that very much
goes to Americans who are being unjustly
detained including Paul Whelan
um and of course uh Evan guskovich we
are focused every day on trying to bring
them and other unjustly detained
Americans home when it comes to
ukrainians who are being detained
civilians as you've heard dimitro refer
to uh as well as prisoners of War of
course Ukraine has been in the lead on
seeking to secure their freedom but if
there are any ways we can support that
effort and help that effort of course
we'll do it
next one goes to CNN Jennifer
thank you so much for doing this both of
you Mr secretary yesterday Russia and
Saudi Arabia announced they would
continue their voluntary oil production
cuts and that's already seen as surge in
oil prices are you concerned that this
is going to have an impact on Americans
at the pump and are there going to be
consequences for Riyadh as was warned
last year when we saw similar moves and
then to both of you today Putin spoke
with MBS and praised their economic
cooperation does this give you concerns
that Saudi Arabia could be an honest
broker and any peace negotiations given
the close ties between the two thank you
[Music]
so our
our focus is on making sure of two
things that um energy
remains readily available and that
there's sufficient Supply on the market
to meet to meet demand and of course
that this is done at a at a reasonable
price
um
we are always looking to see what those
who are producers and suppliers of
energy are doing in terms of in terms of
that supply and the effects that it's
going to have on the market so we will
look at this carefully in the in the
days and weeks ahead to see the results
that it actually produces you can get an
immediate bump in price but that may
quickly settle down
to uh to something lower so it's
something we'll be looking at again with
the objective of ensuring that there is
sufficient energy on World Markets to
meet demand and at a fair price
Ukrainian Soldier is the most on honest
broker in this war
because we all understand that the road
to any diplomatic process
lays through the battlefield
in diplomacy I think that I think one of
the finest Arts of diplomacy is the art
of separation
it's like in cooking
and I believe it's no coincidence that
while Saudi Arabia and Russia discuss
strengthening economic cooperation
Saudi Arabia hosts a very important
meeting in Jeddah dedicated to the
realization of Peace formula proposed by
Ukraine
and I believe that the art of Saudi
diplomacy here is to separate these
tracks
and we welcome their effort
to bring together various countries to
make them sit at the table in Saudi
Arabia and discuss how to restore peace
in Ukraine on Ukraine's terms
this is very important
thank you
my first question is to secretary
blinken uh as we know Ukraine and USA
started talks about security guarantees
uh can you give us a little more
information how's it going and when we
will hear the first maybe results
thank you
so we are focused uh with our Ukrainian
partners and many other countries uh
around the world on on two things one is
in the near term in the immediate term
ensuring that Ukraine has what it needs
to be successful on the battlefield in
pursuing the counter-offensive and
dealing with the current Russian
aggression and an important part of my
visit here today was to do what we've
been doing all along which was to listen
very carefully to our Ukrainian Partners
to understand
what what they need in this moment and
to look at ways to to support that
but even as we're doing that
it's critically important that we and
many other countries that have agreed to
do the same help Ukraine build a force
for the future a military force of the
future that is capable of deterring
future aggression and if necessary
defending and defeating it
um
we now have 29 countries that have
signed on to a declaration issued by the
G7 at the end of the NATO Summit that is
focused on doing just that helping
Ukraine build this Force future and
we're in the early stages of talking
directly with with Ukraine about what
the the different elements would be
other countries are similarly engaged or
beginning to engage in those
conversations and as I indicated that
will I think play out over uh over the
coming months
um
it's important because
we want to make sure that
Ukraine is in a position for the long
term not just today to deter aggression
and to defend against it
we need President Putin to understand
that
he cannot Outlast Ukraine he cannot
Outlast Ukraine's supporters that
Ukraine is actually going to grow
stronger
and even more effective with uh a
military force that is world class
but also
a strong and vibrant economy
and a strong and vibrant democracy so
all of these things together are
the recipe for as I said earlier the
Ukraine that not only survives
this Russian aggression but thrives in
the future that's the best possible
response to what Putin has done so
this work on
um
helping Ukraine build long-term
deterrence and defense as I said we're
beginning to engage in those
conversations in detail but this will be
something that we work on in the coming
months
Ukrainian
um
[Music]
foreign
uh foreign
thank you
thank you everyone and good evening